so let me take you back 10 years and
steve job
jobs kicked off the smartphone
revolution when he introduced the iphone
and on the iphone there was kind of a
mobile browser but it was a pretty poor
experience of going online
so a year later he kicked off the app
store
and you've got the native apps and this
is a really good way of getting online
and interacting with online content and
i'm sure you've all used
loads of apps over the last 10 years uh
maybe
the gmail app for sending emails maybe
use twitter for sending tweets
snapchat sending delightful pictures of
yourself
and then there's plenty of you i'm sure
who wasted many weeks and months uh
playing the king of apps flappy birds
but since uh since 2008 the mobile web
has increased
dramatically when you're out and about
i'm sure that many of you are looking at
urls
in your chrome browser but native apps
have a huge benefit in loads of areas
so first of all we're going to talk
about performance so native apps are
fast and quick to respond
when you first get out your mobile phone
you've got a really nice icon that you
can click on
straight away as soon as you click on
that you get a really nice scaffolded
uh app that comes up let's say you're
going to facebook it's kind of a nice
blue
look and you've got a facebook icon
you've probably got a load of cash
content so when i get my twitter app up
i've got a load of tweets there so i see
those straight away
there's no going into chrome and trying
to find a url and trying to load up a
page
they also have a smooth consistent
self-contained ui so the native app
looks really good on your phone you kind
of enjoy using it it kind of feels you
know exactly where you are
and the killer piece for a native app is
it works consistently well offline
so whether you should be checking your
emails on the tube that's another matter
but you can check your emails on the
tube
they've been synced during the day you
can then sit back and reply to one of
those emails
when you become a come above ground off
it goes it all works well
if you try and do that with a mob with a
normal web app
it doesn't work but why aren't native
apps everywhere why aren't we using
native apps for everything we do if
we've got all these benefits
anyone developing native apps here
we got one person here how is it this is
cool
cool great okay so i'm not a native app
developer uh
i've just heard a few stories that uh it
can be painful
so there's different languages between
android and ios so you've got java
maybe you're funky in hipster and use
kotlin um otherwise you're using swift
you can use react native but you still
have to change the way you develop a
whole load of things so there's a
different way of doing css
even within react native you have to do
different stuff depending on the
platform you're on
and even then you can have to develop
differently for the web so you're
already some developer developing for
three different platforms
it's expensive to develop um expense is
very subjective
so if your business depends on an app
you really need to develop that app so
you need to run three teams
and that's really part of how your
business works but if you're a small
startup or you're trying to do an app on
the side of a bigger business
then this can be incredibly expensive to
have sort of three different platforms
to support
so last year we introduced an iphone app
called monogram
and it's completely different from our
main business and we had a whole
separate team to do that
it was kind of an experiment into how
the social world worked and whether we
could
make a social app work uh it was just
incredibly expensive to keep a separate
team just purely focused on what was an
experiment
and i'm sure there's lots of startups
and companies out there which have
really struggled to support
native apps and all the different
platforms
and then there's also the application
process so i think this has got a lot
better
maybe 10 years ago it's pretty painful
but there's still a process to get into
the app store
there's a different one to get into
android and then even the release
process
we've just seen if you want to release
stuff on the web it's out there it goes
to your customers straight away
with a native app you have to rely on
your customers that they're constantly
updating their phones
i don't know much about that much about
native app doing there's a really good
video from kate huston at the lead dev
so if you're interested these slides
will go around
you can go and have a look at that by
the way this is
progressive web apps so obviously
progressive web apps to the rescue
and this is javascript roundabout right
so one of the best things about
progressive web apps is it uses web
standard technology
he uses javascript thank god i talked
about javascript javascript meetup
it's got most of the benefits of native
apps including performance again crowbar
performance stuff in there um
right once work everywhere so everyone's
hopefully building responsive websites
fingers crossed it's a little bit some
move that aren't but most mostly we're
responsive
um but you just build it once and
hopefully it should work everywhere
you have one team maybe you need a few
tweaks depending on for mobile and uh
yeah you still have to test it on ieee
um
so ie89 but let's zoom on that for a
moment
but what does progressive mean
so everyone in the javascript world's
heard of progressive enhancement
hopefully from back in the days so in
the old days we just have static html
pages
and then javascript came around and we
wanted to enhance our pages
so this design pattern there was the
javascript can make the app
faster and feel better but if you didn't
run javascript it would still work
really well and it's the kind of same
thing with progressive enhancement
there's a whole bunch of features that
you can add to your app
there's 11 the google list and each of
these
should improve the experience for the
customer but if their platform doesn't
have one of those features it shouldn't
break your app
so again this progressive web app is a
case of extra technologies that can add
to the performance of your app
with more of the features you see the
benefits across desktop and web i kind
of always keep comparing against native
apps here
but a lot of these performances are also
on the website so if you have a website
you don't really care so much about your
mobile customers
a lot of these technologies can really
improve the performance of your websites
uh and here's the link so if you go
there there's a whole bunch of 11 really
cool things that google lists
i'm going to talk about a couple of
those uh in a little example i've got
you can go there some of them are like
you need https on your site hopefully
most important websites got https
there's a bunch of stuff
ranging from that through to your
website should work offline
cool so i'm going to give you an example
that's kind of enough like top level
talking
we might even show you some javascript
as well and
i kind of always wanted to build a
native app but it felt like a huge
amount of effort to
learn the process and learn the
different languages and learn the
structure and
get the app out into the app store but i
have built some side projects
some single page apps and the other week
i was like well i've kind of always
wanted to try and get one of these to
maybe be an app
how how can it be so i read a few blogs
about progressive web apps
and there's some terms there they didn't
understand but you still sit there for a
day and bang your head against the wall
and eventually these things kind of play
out and it was a lot of the same
technologies i use in my day-to-day work
so it felt quite comfortable
now the type of side project that works
really well is a single page app because
a bit like a native app you've got kind
of a structure on your page and you're
updating some of the content through
some api calls off in the background
this is my blog i apologize for the
design i'm not an amazing designer
there's lots of white space and some
green stuff around
and just about that technology and
everyone's using react but this is
handlebars and jquery
that old school um it's isomorphic
which means that you get the initial
render of the page from the server it's
fully rendered
so we've got handbars rendering on the
server side and yeah the single page app
so we're going to talk a little bit more
about some of the key features
of a progressive web app and why just
having a few endpoints really helps
sort of do the testing for that
so there's three steps let's see if
there's any javascript in the first step
json is json javascript let's say yes
um first of all manifest.json this is
just
some config if you can just about read
that it's basically got a name for my
app
it's got a link to an icon i want to
appear on the home page of the phone
and it's got some theme colors so this
is back to that ui
do you want a kind of consistent theme
color to your app when it opens up on
your phone
oh that's step one step two
no javascript here but we want to link
to the manifest.json in the head of your
html
so it's just a link with a manifest tag
there
the other part that you put in the head
of the html is a theme color
so you saw my app that was kind of white
with a bunch of green there
this is for anyone who knows the hex
that's kind of green
and this is a screenshot from my app on
my phone
and you can see that that top bar is
already that green color which it fits
in
with the theme of my app
cool step three service worker
i'd heard loads about service workers
and kind of got in my head that they
were really complicated
and there's a load of javascript with a
bunch of promises so if you know your
promises
uh service workers are kind of not too
bad let's jump the script yeah
javascript
roundabout here you
proxy server good
so the service worker sits between the
browser
and the network it's a proxy server
and there's a bunch of javascript logic
and you can manage your cache
programmatically
basically you get access to any of the
requests that come in from the front end
and you can do what you want with it i'm
going to go through a little example of
just a very simple one that i did for my
app
um matt already talked a little bit
about varnish and setting headers and
stuff
some of that sort of vco language and
the headers can be a little obtuse and
this is a more programmatic way of
managing that cache
in the browser uh cloudfront are
actually gonna
allow service workers to sit on the edge
so if anyone's dealt with vcl varnish
config language this is going to be a
way of using javascript in your cdn
cool it's a progressive web apps first
first of all we want to check that our
app
or that our client can can use service
workers
so this is just my main.js which is my
main javascript file for my app
and just check that i can use service
workers and then register my service
worker
and i've got this service worker file
which is sat in the root of my directory
second bit we've got a cache name and
then a bunch of files that i want to
cache
so the service worker is this proxy
server and all i want to do is
have a whole list of files and assets i
want to cache and sit there
the service worker will store that and
it means that when my app's offline
i can hopefully use this cache to serve
that content to my customers
as you can see my app's not super
complicated there's an api which i can
get all my posts from
it's worth noting you can you don't have
to be limited to routes that are in your
domain so here i'm getting some google
api stuff some fonts
i've got a couple other javascript files
there
so that's the first step
second step you get my service worker
there's an event listed for installing
and i want to do some logic when it
starts installing
this is the key line cache to add all
the files to cache it's that full list
of
files i had before i try and add them to
my cache
my service worker goes through that
whole loop goes off to the network
fetches content for every single one of
those routes
and that backs into my cache promises so
you've got an e wait until so this is
kind of promised it's waiting till all
those files are added into the cache
when that's finished it says my server's
working service worker is installed
ready to go
after it's installed the next thing i
want to do is if someone in the app
requests anything
i want to interrogate that request and
then i can do what i want with the cache
this is a very very simple example that
on any fetch request
i go through my caches caches.match and
i check to see if the request that's
come from my server is in my cache
if i do have a response i'm just going
to send that straight back
so if you're talking about performance
if there is something in my class there
i'm going to send that straight back
to the client and my page is going to
render immediately otherwise i'm going
to send off the request out to the
network and hopefully it's going to come
back to me
this is kind of one caching strategy
just a couple of lists of other things
you can do
you could return the cache immediately
and refresh that cache in the background
maybe cool off to the network first but
if your network's really slow let's say
your user is on a 3g network
maybe you call off and if nothing's come
back within one or two seconds you can
return whatever's in the cache
you can do a whole lot of logic in here
so if you know that your customers at
certain points in the journey and they
will need some other assets further on
you can call off in the service worker
and go and get some images let's say
they're looking through
an album of photos you're going to go
and pre-fetch some of the photos in the
next page
as you've got some pagination you can go
and get some content from the next step
you can even sort of build up the dom or
build up some html in the service worker
so that the next step in the app
is is really quick for the customer
cool almost native i'm just going to
show you some screenshots here so this
is
what happens when those three changes so
i did the manifest.json
added the little content in the top of
the page and i've added the service
worker
this is what you get so i open my app up
in my chrome thing
my chrome thing my chrome browser and a
little button pops up at the bottom
so it's a really simple way of allowing
your app
to get added to the home screen of your
phone so instead of going to an app
um into the app store and installing it
as soon as you open up
my web page you get this little button
uh i built an icon you could probably
build a better icon but you can see
there on the right
the blog nice little green green thing
uh there's a couple of other icons there
there's a hacking news one there which
is a progressive web app someone's built
a hacking news
with vue.js the rest of those are all
native apps
as soon as you click on the blog you get
this really nice green screen again with
my terrible icon in the middle
and the name of my blog there
and once that's opened up you get the
whole page here the great thing about
this is you don't get the
url bar at the top so you can see that
this screen on the right
looks and feels just like you'd
installed a native app
all we've done is written maybe 30 lines
of javascript we have maybe 20 lines of
adjacent we can add a couple of things
in the html of the head
you don't have to go through any app
store or any other kind of process to
get this
onto someone's phone
and it works offline and it's fast with
a slow network i'm going to carry on
with the size we can double check that
it works offline
live demo is always terrible but it does
uh when i'm on my phone i can go read my
whole blog
i wrote it so hopefully i should
remember what it is my mom gets to read
it when she's at home and she doesn't
have internet connection
so she's really happy
cool i'm just going to show you a few
tools that you can use to help debug the
the app i think i get really stuck in my
development that i use the same things
in the
google chrome console it's really cool
to know there's other things that are
there
um i think there's loads of things i'm
way off uh learning about
the application side there's a whole
chunk of stuff on the service workers
and you can see a lot of the sort of
process and flow of your service worker
and exactly what's stored in the cache
if you haven't discovered it yet in
chrome there's also an audit tab it's a
bit like web page test so it does a
whole bunch of audits for your
app so you can also look at performance
here
but there's a four schools and one of
those requests progressive web app store
uh
web app score um i'm doing a talk about
it so thank god i got 100 out of 100.
um there's a there's 11 past audits here
you can click on them so if you've got
an app
you'll probably pass a few of them like
if you have https you've already scored
one point out of 11.
there's a whole bunch of other things
there with little tips and links on how
to get your app to be progressive
uh imagine google they're starting to
use more and more
that people's websites work well on
mobile for their rankings i imagine at
some stage in the future
something like the score on the
progressive web app will be part of
their rankings
gotchas there's always gotchas one of
the two hardest things in computer
science
so cash and validation naming things and
off by one errors
caching is hard we get it wrong all the
time we get it wrong with murloc there's
been outages
in the two years that i've been there
because we screw up headers and we mess
things up
caching is hard don't cache customer
user data if it shouldn't be cached
you really want to give someone else's
private data to someone else that's my
number one tip for today
so if you don't remember anything else
don't cache people's data when you
shouldn't
uh in chrome sometimes you have two tabs
open
and the service record work is
registered with one and you try and
refresh and it doesn't refresh the
service worker
and then you try and change some other
stuff and you close all your tabs and
you close chrome and you open up again
it's still not working and then you
realize you've been refreshing the live
site not your dev version
um but that's just javascript debugging
for you but there are some little
gotchas with service workers
that you kind of need to get used to
when you're trying to work with it
finally what your app works offline
always even on localhost
so i've been developing i shut my app
down i came in a couple of days later
i opened up python simple server it was
running on the same host i went to my
browser
and it refreshed the app that i've been
working on three days ago because it's
been stored for offline use
so this new thing i've been working on
uh was sat behind
my offline app so you just have to make
sure you change your port number
and remember that this thing is stored
in your cache somewhere or delete it and
get rid of it
cool so conclusion progressive web apps
awesome
website and technologies that can be
improved used to improve the performance
yeah we've got performance in again
and feel of your website build wants
work everywhere it's javascript yay
cool thank you very much